Amateur terrorist attacks and soap made from
liposuction fat?
"Fight Club" can be a confusing ride — but
we're here to help.
The first two rules of "Fight Club" are to
never talk about Fight Club, but the film
itself also has a rule: never reveal the Narrator's
name.
The film avoids mentioning the name of the
protagonist, who's only called "Narrator"
in the ending credits.
The character stays nameless so that he can
represent anyone who has lost their sense
of self and individuality.
"Fight Club" cleverly references his lack
of a name when he is simply addressed as "sir"
by members of the club.
The film goes as far as to give him multiple
names as he attends various support groups
under aliases.
Marla Singer even asks him about it when they
first meet,
"It doesn't have your name.
Who are you?
Cornelius?
Rupert?”
[honking]
“Any of these stupid names you give each
night?"
Meanwhile, the narrator frequently uses the
phrase "I am Jack's sense of..." to express
how he is feeling at any given time.
This is a reference to articles that he reads
early in the film.
"I am Jack's medulla oblongata.
Without me, Jack cannot regulate his heart
rate, blood pressure, or breathing."
The text on the "Fight Club" DVD, as well
as its bonus features, refer to the character
as Jack, and the chapter list for the film
is called "Jack's Chapters."
The character is also referred to as Jack
in the official shooting screenplay, which
Norton confirmed in the DVD commentary of
the movie.
You would never describe Marla's relationship
with the Narrator as "healthy."
Marla regularly expresses her frustration
with the Narrator's behavior towards her.
"You are such a nutcase, I can't even begin
to keep up"
Even the Narrator doesn't know that he's in
a sexual relationship with her until he realizes
that he himself is Tyler Durden, with whom
Marla has been having sex.
Before that realization, the Narrator doesn't
seem to like her as a person, and therefore
Tyler doesn't respect her.
Viewers would wonder, among other things,
why Marla would continue to stay with the
Narrator with everything he's putting her
through.
It's established that the chain-smoking Marla
has grown accustomed to leading a self-destructive
lifestyle, possibly to the point that she
views toxic relationships as normal.
This might come from the character's low self-esteem,
which makes her drawn to the Narrator especially
after he intervened as she tried to end her
own life.
After the Narrator meets Tyler Durden on the
plane, he's drawn to the mysterious soap salesman
who seems to be the complete opposite of himself.
There are times before their initial encounter
when the Narrator may not have noticed Tyler's
presence, but audiences have.
With the exception of the first time Tyler
is clearly seen on the escalator, he's only
briefly visible to eagle-eyed viewers in single-frame
flashes.
Given that Tyler was likely controlling the
Narrator's body while he slept, these single
frame flashes could be remnants of his memories
while sleepwalking.
The explosion at the Narrator's condo was
caused by Tyler, and it happened before they
met on the plane.
This implies that Tyler had been plotting
and acting before he ever met the Narrator
on the plane.
"The first rule of Fight Club is: you do not
talk about Fight Club.”
And despite that also being the second rule
of Fight Club, the club not only continues
to attract new members, but eventually transforms
into Project Mayhem, an anarchist organization
run by Tyler.
Even though Tyler scolds the club for breaking
the rule, he doesn't seem to mind that it's
growing.
After all, breaking the rules is what Fight
Club is all about.
When the Narrator runs into Bob after a long
time, Bob is excited to talk all about a new
club he's attending.
"Well, the first rule is, I'm not supposed
to talk about it."
The Narrator tells him that he's part of the
same club too, and they talk about Fight Club
without saying its name.
It's possible to imagine that word of Fight
Club spread like this, with people talking
about the club as though it were a support
group for them which it arguably was.
Fight Club and Project Mayhem eventually grow
to include hundreds of members over multiple
cities, functioning as an army with plans,
weapons, and explosives.
Project Mayhem aims to bomb several credit
card company buildings, an operation which
would have to take a lot of money.
So how did Tyler and his army find the funds
needed to support such a massive undertaking?
To finance Fight Club, Tyler had been making
luxury soap from the fat dumped in the garbage
facilities of liposuction clinics, which he
would sell for $21 dollars apiece.
Still, since Tyler seems to be the sole proprietor
of his small-scale soap business, he wouldn't
generate enough revenue alone to support the
club.
Project Mayhem doesn't just sell soap to make
money, though.
The Narrator even blackmails his boss with
compromising information about their company
in exchange for a full salary and perks as
an "outside consultant."
While this provides one source of income,
it still doesn't explain how Project Mayhem
could afford to pull off their master plan.
However, it is pretty likely that Project
Mayhem's many members may have contributed
their own earnings to support the club's movement.
At the climax of the film, Tyler appears to
have the upper hand on the Narrator, since
Tyler doesn't really exist and therefore can't
be hurt.
However, the Narrator eventually realizes
that if Tyler is holding a gun, so is the
Narrator himself.
He turns the tables by taking control of Tyler's
gun himself and finding a new way to deal
with Tyler by shooting himself.
The gunshot wound isn't fatal enough for the
Narrator to pass out; he can still talk to
his soldiers and Marla, although barely.
The more you think about it, the more questions
arise about the logic of Tyler's death.
What specifically causes Tyler Durden, who
exists only in the Narrator's head, to believe
that he has been killed by a single bullet
to the Narrator's jaw?
One explanation is that the entire final showdown
is more of a mental struggle within the Narrator's
head than it is a physical one.
After realizing that he is ultimately the
one in control, the Narrator shoots himself
non-fatally in order to finally get rid of
Tyler once and for all.
With the tagline "Mischief.
Mayhem.
Soap." and the film's title inscribed on a
pink soap bar, soap was a key aspect of the
marketing and plot of the film.
The Narrator is introduced to Tyler Durden,
a seemingly successful luxury soap entrepreneur.
Only after spending more time with Tyler and
getting to know him better does the Narrator
learn the gruesome way Tyler makes his soaps.
While soap is a cleaning agent, the history
of soap manufacturing is unpleasant.
In Ancient Mesopotamia, soap had been made
by cooking fats obtained from slaughtered
animals.
Along with being symbolic of this sacrifice,
soaps also have a history of being a luxury
item, only being available to European aristocracy.
Tyler, who despises wealth and vanity, sells
soap made from the fat of rich people to the
very same people later, and no one's the wiser.
It fits into his anti-capitalist mantra perfectly,
which is why it's used as an icon for the
movie itself.
To anyone watching "Fight Club" for the first
time, the few single-frame "blips" that appear
in the initial few minutes of the film can
be disorienting and confusing.
It's only after a second watch when you may
realize it was Tyler who "blipped" in these
frames which is something Tyler does at his
job in the film itself.
If you pause on the frames, you would see
Tyler striking relaxed poses, as though he
were foreshadowing his meeting with the Narrator.
It's also possible that Tyler had been operating
behind the Narrator's back whenever the Narrator
was asleep.
Tyler's memories and personality may have
begun to bleed into the Narrator's conscious
mind, which may be why Tyler finally introduces
himself to the Narrator.
In Marvel's "Moon Knight," a similar situation
occurs in a more modern setting.
Marc Spector had been able to function without
Steven Grant being aware that he has a second
personality, but eventually, it wasn't possible
to keep that a secret from Steven anymore.
It's interesting to note that both Steven
Grant and "Fight Club's" Narrator have troubles
with insomnia, which play into their alternate
identities as "Moon Knight" and "Tyler Durden".
Marla's frustration with the Narrator should
have been one of the first clues toward "Fight
Club's" big twist, that he and Tyler Durdin
are the same person.
Upon rewatching the film, it becomes a kind
of game to find the moments and scenes where
the Narrator was actually Tyler Durden.
The film uses his behavioral changes, intentional
continuity errors, and other easter eggs planted
to indicate to the audience which is which.
One clear example of the Narrator being more
Tyler than himself happens when the Narrator's
boss confronts him on his erratic behavior
since joining Fight Club.
The Narrator responds rudely and threatens
his boss.
"He's a button-down, Oxford-cloth psycho who
might just snap and stalk from office to office…"
"...pumping round after round into colleagues
and coworkers."
This kind of intimidation seems out of character
for the usually meek Narrator, and is similar
to Brad Pitt's unsettling portrayal of Tyler
Durden.
While Tyler's attitude and manner of life
are supposed to be influencing him, it appears
that the Narrator is almost being "possessed"
by Tyler in this scene.
It's also interesting to see that the Narrator's
goatee-like stubble in the sequence matches
that of Tyler's.